we've got a voicemail number it's to 192
david p yesterday we had a voicemail
from someone saying david no you're
wrong
saplings remove more carbon from the
atmosphere than fully grown trees today
we have a caller who says no david
yesterday's caller is wrong let's take a
listen I'm calling to disagree with what
that guy said about five little trees
versus one big tree if trees grew like
human beings where it grew to be a
certain size and then stopped growing he
would be right but trees continued to
grow for their entire lives and add
trees eventually do release their co2
one way or another the house burns down
or gets knocked over by a hurricane or a
tornado an earthquake eventually or
eaten by termites well the important
thing is the oxygen the big tree has
more leaves and it makes more oxygen
yeah that's what I want to say all right
that that was why I at first said when
you take down one tree and plant two or
five saplings my instinct is that the
saplings are not sequestering as much
carbon yesterday's caller said no they
sequester more because they are growing
but then this caller is saying no the
trees grow indefinitely so it doesn't
matter I really don't know the answer
this is a very very specific science
question and I just don't know the
answer to it but it's a very interesting
debate that's going on on today's bonus
show Donald Trump's traitor rhetoric is
being considered a factor in the
sentencing of bowe bergdahl we will talk
about new flight paths for airplanes all
over the country that are leading to
massive noise complaints and also I will
tell you about Bill O'Reilly recently
publicized sexual harassment settlements
yes yet another one don't miss the bonus
show david pakman.com slash membership
is how you sign up you can also access
the bonus show with a $5 or greater
contribution at patreon.com slash david
pakman show we will speak to you on the
bonus show in mere minutes